hola qué tal en esta segunda jornada de
la convención demócrata una convención
virtual la esposa del candidato
demócrata joe bytes gb será la encargada
de dar el discurso central ella va a
hablar sobre la trayectoria profesional
de bairén y también su rol como hombre
de familia igualmente durante estas
jornadas esperan testimonios a través de
vídeos de muchos votantes que se han
visto afectados durante la pandemia y
también que han tenido que sufrir según
lo dicen los demócratas la falta de
liderazgo del presidente de donald trump
y ese será el tema central de esta noche
el liderazgo hablarán también dos
importantes ex presidentes demócratas
carter y bill clinton y se espera la
intervención de el líder del senado
chuck schumer al igual que al ex andrea
cortez quien tiene una gran cantidad de
seguidores jóvenes